Tete Hashi
Watch Umecha
Usually
5th place Etin 5th place Type Ray
ana
Wavefire
andare
car
All campaign
Chibimine m m
goo
me
Ah ah ah
tan
Bandai 7 pieces
Taipei Game Show delivered from entertainment
today 2022
I would like to introduce Elden Ring, which will be released on February 25,
2014. Today's evolution will be Araki.
Thank you for your cooperation.
And Mr. Kitao of From Software will be with you
today.  Now, as for
today's content, the bus will
give you an overview of the Elden Ring and its appeal
.
After that
, it will be time to answer any questions or requests regarding Elden that Ashiya has applied in advance.
So I hope you enjoy the
Parrows network
test in November. Yes
, how was the response
? Not only in Asia, but we received a lot of applications from all over the world.
It's the color of the person who actually touched it. It's just
ep and a bag,
so it seems that there are two red games.
Thank you very much for the excitement when I went out to
that wide field, but I received a relatively good feed,
but of course 4 I got a lot of feed bags that I wanted to do more or I would like an
improved car.
It's the same with the master, and it's in the form of being developed in response to the Eating Spirit One
Patch.
The title of that bath software.
What about the reaction of the people
? That was the time of the previous talk, and I was
invited to various events in the Asian region, and the
users are really enthusiastic.
I was impressed right
away, and until then, the Western events
had already entered quite a bit, wasn't it?
However,
I was happy to know that there are so many of our fans in the Asian region, and I was really happy to receive that kind of
research
.
That's right, I also feel the expected value. Of course,
I wanted to go to various areas this time as well,
but after all
it will be like this because of the influence of Corona, but if it is cured now,
I definitely want to
play.  It's a work scene, but I understand that I
want to go. Then, I would like to
introduce a lot about the Elden ring, but first of all
, please see the latest video.
Permanent residence burger
and live corner in surfing c 2
ran Aichi part  24
I'm saying
far
Nu hand-knitted cars Pican tea 4
stage Booker and India Let's buy
this Inner cover A little
point on the boss roll
[Music]
Pusher qnc Let's take a photo Aun
Return brog
Wing Spoon
[Music]
Bailoon
Wow ah ah
I'm already making none 2
uh
[Music]
[Music] It
was a complete pace
ani
Azurejo Make Hey, I'm aiming for it
p The location of the tube Town name
none
me
[Music]
Standing big pin installation
Straight blue that got stuck on a lie
12 mi Zu Leader Ocha
[Music]
Annas 4
I'm saying wish I can imagine
various stories from the video you watched,
but
please explain in detail
.
I think that some people are enjoying the elding, but of
course there are many people who do not know yet, but it
is the basic part of the entry, so I will
introduce it
really the basics.  First of all, it's the
dark fantasy action rpg
.
This is the heavy action
rpg, the confusion and the sense of accomplishment, and the
unknown exploration or the
creation of the world view.  Hey, we're up to
this  I've come to
develop it with the concept
of creating a new experience by incorporating abundantly in art through such discussions as to whether
it has been cultivated through the development of the Dark Souls series Platt book and
so far while recruiting firmly.  Masu Yes
Today, I will explain the world view and the action system
roughly. Yes,
the world view is a part.
We have adopted the first open field in this work.  It
presents a world with a wintering scale above
that. In
that big world,
that kind of thing is being developed based on the myth created by George r r Martin. In
other
words, the world and the game volume itself
will become larger.  The story told there
is also a more multi-layered
form.
What about the fusion with Mr. Miyazaki of From Software
? Well, this time it's a slightly strange
form, or the story of the game itself.  It's not that
Martin wrote
this, isn't it
the origin of the world of this oil field ring? The old part
We read it like a myth,
but he wrote that.
Miyazaki was originally
a big fan of marty, and
they knew that it was dark, so the
story started
and led to this collaboration,
isn't it
?  I asked everyone to change that mythical part
, but I
was told that I would leave the rest to from, and
the body that he wrote
was inspired by the free idea layer
Miyazaki this time.  It feels like you're making a story about it, and
you
can tell that it's already heavy.
It's the story part.
To put it very simply, that stage is about to come,
but it was originally prosperous, but
uh, why is it getting more and more devastated, so I
'm outside the house in the gap
.  Sweat 1 This is this time  I'm the main character,
but
after this gap,
there was a kind of detective who had
a lot of elding and
went up.
Well, it's a story that challenges the Demi Gods,
so this time too, I think
that there are 8 catchy stories that are easier to enter
than ever before.
I wonder what it
is. Rather than getting the hero involved in something, it's
more like going on an adventure where you're going to be the king on your own initiative
. Yes,
various characters will appear, but
each one is related to this kind of ringing.
A group image drama will be developed
this time as well. That was the same as our title until now,
but
we are aiming for the player's play itself to become a story,
and
that movie  Rather than presenting this kind of story very
clearly, it's a jet
fragmentary
story, and if you think about the story inside,
it's a prediction that you can imagine what it
's like.  We are preparing well this time as well,
so if you like that part,
it has more volume than ever before,
so
I think you should expect it.
Dark soul flowers are considered.
That's right, you will cross a lot,
and it's still
equivalent to the flavor of the item, isn't it? This time the
item itself
is quite a
lot in the Dark Soul series.  a
I think it's easier for that user to understand what the situation is like now because they talk about the world
. Yes,
so I guess that's what I imagined in my own way.
I think
it's a story that is easier to immerse than ever, although there is room to do it.
Next, I
will talk about the composition of the map. As I said earlier,
this time it's an open field.
I'm adopting
This field isn't just that wide,
it's a fin that is full of various dangers and
has many battle scenes in the patriotism
.
After that
, small and medium-sized men and women who seamlessly connect to exploring may find
it. There
are various discoveries just by exploring in the form that you can capture it.
That kind of game density.  I
'm aiming for a high field of exploration. It
's seamlessly connected
to the building. Of course, there are several types of
small and medium-sized dungeons such as
catacombs and labor,
but basically.  It does
n't matter if it's clear or not, but of course
there is a terrifying boss there, and Ose
is waiting for the reward,
so
I want to run around if I can enjoy such a strategy.
Enzyme I think this experience is also
a part that you can enjoy. For
those small and medium-sized men and women, the
open is a tweet in the field.
We call it a legacy dungeon,
but a large dungeon is prepared.
This is different from that field. It's
complicated and three-dimensional, so
you can enjoy that rather tense strategy
.
Naon That
's the openness of the field.
Exploring with a sense of tension in the space
You can enjoy even those two different play peels.
Unlike the feeling of openness outside, it seems that you feel nervous just by looking at it.
But, of course, it's not just one by one,
it's like us. There are
various
winter map situations, so
I hope you enjoy a lot of exploration
.
How wide is it? How much is it? 5
o
I haven't gotten up like how many Tokyo dome I've planned, but
that's right.
hand  It's like meeting
. It
's a place with various tastes in the slides I've just seen. For the first time, the
fill itself has quite a
difference in height
, so there is a story that if it's wide, it's a god work or the color is troublesome.
I think that this time
we have prepared such a map and it is
a so-called checkpoint that has already been issued a ticket.
You can always do that first
love there. Since it is
from the map
, the progress of the game itself is also a married user this time.
I want you to capture it freely, so I try
not to go there so much and
do as much as possible to induce strong like ice
, but on the other hand, it's okay if it's Seo.
Since there are things that are easy to do, it is in the form of preparing some
systems that do not do so as much as possible
.
Next, action and system. Yes
, it's a meeting talk party player character
.  At the latest equator where I spend a lot of time, the main
character was to make fixed Nogami um,
but this time it
's like the dark soul season
.  It
seems that there are equipment and web ability values.In
this way,
for example,
you can choose a play style that makes dogs more and
more extremely popular.  You can
create a character that touches heavy weapons in a shape
. Yes,
that's right. For example, if you're not good at close combat,
you can create a character that makes full use of bows like this.
This is magic. This time, the concept is magic and turtle head, but the
idea is
to attach a bib that specializes
in magic.
Of course, that's the same as before,
but there's only one so-called
character.  It's not a class-like concept
,
so if you raise each ability score, you can of course
make 8 characters that can master all dogs
, bows, heavy weapons, and people.  Be done  At that
time, was the style made as good as the style of the prefecture so far
? I'm always a little dog.
It's said that it became garbage This time, if you didn't play the oil field ring yourself,
it smelled like one and
it changed to a way of playing.
After all, the field is open, so the
basic system is
dark.  There is a part similar to the soul series,
but after all
it feels like the playing era will change if the field is different
.
I think
it's a feeling, but the field is appropriate
Well, it's fun to think
about how to attack because the player discovers the enemy first and is there, of
course, it's fun to capture the bow, isn't it?
In that sense, let's go after defeating some of them.
That's how the era of playing changes,
so I'm also the same.
Let's try using a lot of bows this time
.
I don't think there are many people who change, I also
swung my sword in the closed network test
.
Especially this time,
it's more flashy than the Kapo series,
which has a keen taste. There are many such things
, so just using it makes it a fun
way to write.  I
wonder if that's what I think people who used only melee weapons and this time will feel like trying it. It
seems that a
different experience will come out. Yes,
this is a spirit body.
Where there is a strong enemy and where there is a boss, you can call an
example of becoming a companion who did not
have you. It is a
form that you can fight
together. You can also strengthen the spirit body itself.
Since there are various types after that, in this
situation,
select such a spirit body in the form of calling this rater.
I think it's fun to grow,
but it disturbed the enemy quite a bit.
That's right, so after
all,
especially in boss battles, it takes a so-called target,
so
it's quite helpful even in difficult places.
But of course it's not very strong, so it
helps me at the beginning, but
I wonder if I have to do my
best from the middle of it.
I think it will become an existence
[Music]
Next is stealth.
I prepared that stealth this time, and if I
crouch down or stay in the shade of a tree, it
will be difficult for the enemy to use it,
so if the enemy is now a woman, that's
right.  You can hide like this and
overdo it, or you can sneak up and assassinate from
behind.
Then, while exploring various things,
if you think that it seems to be a little strong, it's about time.
However, avoiding it
is that the octopus escapes to the phrase, so it is in the form
of that action rpg this time,
but that
rpg Osaka is getting stronger and
this kind of spirit body is also the same.  I am preparing a
means of capture other than direct combat
to the world of stealth, so I am not good
at action, but
it seems to be interesting as an rpg, or if you are interested in the world view,
I enjoy this time.
I'm glad that you can do
it. It
's a little difficult just to hear the promus software game
. It's definitely a lot. That's
right, so I've been interested in it so far, but that's a little
like that.  I think that even those
who couldn't get their hands on it because I heard it difficult would
be able to enjoy it. Well, there
is
also a system for all level-ups
.  Online multiplayer It's a
problem, so if it's difficult, you can ask someone to
help you to move forward
. The
next characteristic
is the raver.
You can call it at any time except during Dungeon Light Multiplayer
. It's a finger whistle like now. It's in the form of being able to turn off and summon its spring
, so
there is a considerable difference in height between the fields,
but
Toho Beni.  It's a field with a height difference on the air flow
oo Yes
,
you can actually move over the winter as it is, it's a horse with a
fairly high exercise performance such as being able to jump two steps,
isn't it
?  Of course, you can run around without a
horse. Of course, you can do a public bath while riding a horse. It's the year of the horse or the year of the horse
.
I think
that you don't have to ride a horse when there is a big enemy in the field, but it is
also advantageous to apply
it.It is
quite advantageous to ride 8 horses depending on the appropriate situation.  I
think that there are times when you can get around, but if you say that there
are a lot of enemies in that narrow space,
I think that fighting will probably be more advantageous if you put your feet in the same way as before
.  I think
it would be better to have a sweet fight against the enemies because such dragons, large enemies, and hits and
aways are the main players. Yes, the best is online.  I talked briefly,
but now you can do winter online multiplayer. This can be done in the
field or in the dungeon, of course
. It's still a cooperative play. It
's a cooperative play that explores together and defeats the boss.
Expected play includes intrusion,
but other
players from other worlds go to their own world and fight. There
is such a multiplayer
. Yes,
this is
the night asynchronous online where the Dark Soul series was.  It's an element.
Overwintering
A message written by a player from another world appears in my own world
.
There are things,
I'm Hammer, I'm married.
That
's a hint, isn't
it? There are also such asynchronous elements. This is also the
same element as the past work, but
after all it's a wide field
and I think that the way of feeling will change.
After all
, it seems that no one will come to such a lot of places like this, so
I'm glad that there is a
message, I think that you can enjoy it with that different feeling.
When I suddenly feel a sense of humor, when I
look at my feet, it looks like another
pooh.
This is a brief introduction to the hot water work, such as why I would like you to send a message to various places this time as well
.
Now, I asked you to tell me about the many rice fields so far
I would like to
ask you to answer the questions and requests you have received. From here, I will answer the questions and requests that you have received in advance from everyone in Asia
. It seems that you have received many questions.
Thank you. Thank you for
your understanding that we cannot answer all the questions
.
First of all, let's start with the first
question.
There will be quizzes for overwintering as before. For wintering, it
will be stronger after taking over the data of your character
. This is the same as before.
Well, that's right, it
's an experience only for the first lap, it's
quite wide, so it's designed so that you can clear it without experiencing the whole thing, so
you can go
around it all from the beginning
.
On the second lap,
you can also play around the wintering
area.
Kotoha 100%, which turns 100% on the first lap
, is 8 so-called a little
Saigon branch, so it's accurate.
Should not be 100% yes yes good
play style  When I was a hard worker,
I leaned toward changing to a magical main, and the other party
also took over and enjoyed it in a different way.
Especially because there is a takeover of that item,
this was the same as I used to be
.  It's a weapon I got in the first lap
, but I'm worried even if I don't use it, but I'm
starting to use it from the week, and that
kind of enjoyment is becoming possible
.  Yes, the
theme doesn't get
stronger, after all, it gets stronger and stronger. I understand it with each rally
.
Now, in the product version, will
it be arranged differently depending on the time and
weather?  The arrangement itself doesn't change
much, but that's right &
I feel like I have to play in all the time zones if the enemy is shaped like curl in all time zones.
I
don't think it's a press because I think there are a lot of people who end up with
it
.
There is
a part where the play style changes a
little depending on the weather, for example, if it is raining heavily
, the visibility of that enemy will be worse,
so it will be easier to spell,
or it will be harder to get scratched.
So there is a difference in that part.
Now is the checkpoint. The
time zone itself can be changed by the blessing. For example,
when running 4 drops on the enemy side
, change the time zone to night and then that.
I think that attacking is one of the strategies.
I see, it's a surprise attack at night.
Then you can think about the situation that is advantageous to
you. That's why it's like the difference between police officers.
By the way, of course,
it's a fairly wide world where the sunset is beautiful or something like that,
but the
ceremony itself will change depending on the time of day and the weather,
so I hope you enjoy that part as well
.
Next, can the world map be moved to g 6 from the beginning
? A The question is, does it mean that you can't enter a new area without
defeating the boss at home?  Well,
as I mentioned earlier that there are several areas
, the first area on the net is a house called
Etrim Grave, like a closed network
. It starts here
, so you can go to all areas from the beginning.
It's not,
but you can go directly to some areas.
It seems that the farther you are from the starting point, the more difficult it is,
so of course
it's a better beer to go after that.
I wonder if
there will be something like that when I come back
. If you are confident in your skills, it seems that you can go out,
so
basically
you can enjoy the strategy
as freely as possible.  Is made a When the close is a
network test
, it was in the form of a legacy leader called Stone Beer from 0 minutes of the wintering ring
, but the Stone Building itself was also
there, there was a boss called Margit
.  Was
it possible to go through that area and go to the next area?
A It's up to the product, but I'm not good at this place, so I went to another place
and raised the level and then returned again  I'm
able to come and do that kind of thing. I just think that if
you don't do this, you can't go next
. I understand.
Next, how many Elding event scenes are
there
?  It's okay, but it's
probably overwintering. Raw k
Sekino itself didn't have any
movies, so the movie was included during the so-called boss battle, so
it's probably
a conversation between that player and the npc.  I
think that's right, there are quite a lot of npc itself this time, and
there is also a place like that round table, which is like a base,
but there are also places
like that where some npc are gathered.
And the conversation there
Of course, it's a story related to the game story,
but
I think that you can enjoy it, so if you
can expect a place such as a seat log, I think that you
can also man this time.
Perhaps the person who
asked this question has a part that
I want it to be delicious rather than considering
it. It seems
that even now, as I told the president, that
npc itself is
involved in Vice Wedding.
Well, after all, if you want to know more that
it will be easier to understand if the character is presented by the government of Stan than it is actually introduced to the winter bottom in the text,
Mr. Miyazaki's
charm
There is a lot of people who want to live, right? Item
Juniors Read the flavor text
and learn more about the world view
.
Next, PlayStation 5 is
PlayStation.  Is there a vibration function for the controller of 5
? But ps 5 is
basically compatible only with the 8 haptic feedback of the controller's vibrator. That
3d onkyo and its surroundings are compatible with the net.  I do
n't have it, but only haptic haptic
feedback is supported.
Okay, how many hours will it take to clear it
?
I think this will vary greatly depending on the player,
but 8 we  The point I'm aiming for now is
that if it's just the so-called main route, I'd like to keep it to about 30
hours.
Well, if it's just the main route
, I'd like to be able to
suppress it that much.
That's right, of course,
if you go around a lot from the first lap, you can play for a longer time, isn't
it?
Well
, I think it's basically a fairly wide world, and
I think that there
are some interesting parts and
many parts that can be stressful.
It's a part that I'm trying to crush as much as possible. It's true that fighting
is difficult,
but if it's stress, it's a little bit
.
It's the
5 experience points earned by the player. I met him in Seoul in the past work.
Well, this rune
was blown on the spot,
and he died from there and
returned to the checkpoint and still it.  I have to go to collect the
heroine, and I'm pretty stressed by the heroine,
so this time it's the so-called chapter.
Where there are a lot of enemies and strong enemies,
it's like a so-called retry point
.  Since I am making a pattern,
I can choose to revive in the immediate vicinity if I die
.
Even so, it is a system implemented from
the point of trying to reduce stress as much as possible
according to the wide field.
Next, what's the difference between the network test version and the product version
? There are a lot of different things that can't
be said in that small part
.
That kind of part will
change, and
the placement of some enemies will also change
. Also, npc. The network
iron wire didn't come, but there are also npc that even have products. Of
course, the basic part of the game itself is
um.  Basically
, it feels like all the closed network tests are included
. That is
, there is a wide field that can be a leveler, and there are
small and medium-sized
dungeons that seamlessly connect from there, and legacy
men and women are ahead.
There is a situation that is not bought big.The part that rides a horse is
also the same.
For example, if it is a really
small part, of course in the
product version, you can customize that player character
, including the appearance.
Yes,
I thought that the closed network test alone was really wide,
but that is many times as many, so
that rim frame itself is also in the middle.
I had to make something like a white wall like this,
but of course there is also that work, and
that wider world is waiting for me, so I
hope you can expect it.
I want you to enjoy the wider world while feeling the differences in various places
.
Next, it took a lot of effort to
modify it by the continuous ring to get the grammar of the level design that
you have accumulated so far.
That's right, that dungeon, especially the legacy
dungeon, is basically made in
the grammar of the action rpg so
far. Of course,
this time the jump action is
included, so the level that matches it.  It's a design,
but will it be a man and a woman? It's
the part of the open feel road,
isn't it? It was our first
challenge, so
we made it through trial and error.  The
biggest thing is, after all, at the
beginning of development, at that first stage, the
field was relatively flat or simple
, so I started with the feeling
of creating a three-dimensional dungeon part
.  However, when
I make it, I think that this is
because people like that kind of game, but the
field itself in London is not flat, and
there is a level of three-dimensional processors.
It's a design
Yes, I
think that made the game itself interesting
. Yes, it's something that hasn't happened before, so it's an
arched type like that over the winter.
You have to put a
lot of lines and do a lot of lines.
Eh, users
can enjoy a stress-free experience without getting
bored. It's the same as the story of the other party, such as the
event or the
placement.  That
's the adjustment that goes to the very end, isn't
it? It's an exquisite balance, but it's a
very difficult place, but I
wonder if it's finally settled.
Please tell me the reason why you implemented the content
that has a big influence on the game, such as climbing a mountain that can call Eva
. Yes
, the number of actions has really increased.
There is a reason, and one is the
adventure in that fantasy world
. When you're trying to explore a wide world, you're a horse
.  One is
that I prepared the wide field as
a means of transportation to comfortably
and without stress. This is also a village and a momoma with as little stress as possible
, but I can jump two steps and win.
If you can summon it on the spot as soon as you choose it, what kind of
shape did
you get?
I
enjoyed the moment when I played the network test and became beautiful
. That's right, it feels good.
It's a system that is implemented with the feeling that it's fun to receive 8
when you want to do something directly above it because it is made with a height difference.
I heard that there was a joy that the swelling of the air flow was connected to such a place.
That Kiryu itself is, of
course, a limited number of places
, but there are relatively many, so
please look forward to it.  There
was such a thing so far I heard that you are doing
your best to receive such feedback, but it
seems that the question is whether the development is going well.
Hey Zenrin originally announced that it will be released in January.
However
, we have postponed the winter release date once a month on the net
.
This time, the release on February 25 is
definitely proceeding with Eto without any problems
.
I'm already developing a patch that will make the game more comfortable and enjoyable by mastering
it. Yes, I understand. That's all for
the question corner.
all
I think
that everyone's expectations for the release are increasing,
but this Elden
Ring will be released on February 25th
. It will be released on the same day in the world.
The platform will be PlayStation
4 Place Tension 5
xbox one xbox series x
and pc. The genre is
action rpg.
And collector's editions will be sold in addition to the regular edition
. Collector's edition will be
sold only on PlayStation 5 PlayStation 4.  The
contents of the package are here.
Elden Ring Game Soft
Miquel's Blade Rarely Star Medium
Art Book
Digital Sound Track and Steel
Book
The blades of these two characters Rarely tomorrow is
23 cm
.  It's the one that is placed in the
store, but it seems that it has been made in quite detail.
Mr.'s designer is also supervising it
.
For those who have made a reservation, we will first
add an adventure guide that contains useful information for the imminent adventure that will be the stage of this work, and
a pose of the gesture ring that can be used in the game.
Please make a reservation as soon as possible.
Please check the Bandai Namco Entertainment website for product information and privilege information
.
Yes, that's all for today
. Mr. Kitao
I hope that all Asian fans have received
it at the end.  The ending is a game that
is quite new to us and has taken on
various challenges, but I
think it has become a worthwhile game to play,
so please
look forward to it. Please enjoy
it.
Thank you very much for watching today
. Goodbye everyone
[Music]
Channel
Recommended Tea
Outside Bike Race
1 to do
the code Champion Ipu has Kan
q Koshiko
[Music]
Yeah yeah
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah [music] ah ah ah
[music]
search results
green
sting voice yeah yeah yeah yeah but
san
today too
ani
me
daily 4
[music]
pasourita reshi
ano
or less before me
na na na
tan
yes